abone ol
ve
Tarsus Amerikan Koleji'nin sevgili
öğrencileri
Değerli
hocalarım mezunları ve Dostları hepinizi
hep birlikte bir arada saygıyla
selamlıyor sevgiyle kucak görmeden
Eğer
siyaset Çalışkan
gelme
sözlerime bir soruyla başlamak istiyorum
şu ma Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nin
gelmiş geçmiş en başarılı başkanı
deyince aklınıza kim geliyor
mi Evet yani George Washington kurucu
General George Washington dan başlayıp
Thomas jefferson
bağımsızlık Bildirisi yazan
ruzgaralti woodrow Wilson sını
Obama'yı
kediyi hep söyleyebiliriz ah böyle
yapacaktık değil
ama benim aklıma hep İbrahim link
ki bu adam
1861 yılında başkan seçilmiş iç savaş
başarısıyla ülkenin bütünlüğünü
pekiştirmiş ve deliği kaldırmış
1965 yılında
tiyatro salonunda vurulduğu koltukta
Antlaşması Şam'a beni
Ama asıl ilgilendiren zim kızın
Amerikan başkanı olarak başarıları da
değil O başarıya giden yolda
ve o yolculuktaki
kararlı Azimli
vazgeçmiyor kazanmak uğruna her türlü
mücadeleyi göze alan Tıp
bakın Amerika Birleşik Devletleri
başkanı seçilmeden önce
iki kez iş denemesi olur İş kurmaya
çalışmış
başaramamış İflas etmiş bir yere eyalet
seçimine girmiş kazanamamış
hasof kalmaz temsilciler Meclisi'ne iki
kez aday olmuş içinde kaybetmiş senatoya
iki kez aday olmuş ikisinide kaybetmiş
Bu bir Başkan seçilmediği önceki seçimde
başkan yardımcısı olarak seçim yarışına
katılmış onu da kaybetmiş
da tam 8 başarısız Kendisi diyor ki
benim iki başarısızlığında var 26
yaşında eşimi kaybettim 27 yaşında
ruhsal Bunalım geçirdi on başarısızlık
11. de adını bir Anıt olarak Amerikan
tarihine yazdırma
Ben bir süre önce Fortune dergisinde de
bu Öykü
başarısızlıklardan sonra elde edilen
başarıya ilişkin öyküyü başarılarıyla
ünlü kişilerle ilgili yapılmış bir
araştırmada okumuştu o ünlü kişiler bu
başarıya ulaşmadan önce o konuda yedi
kez ortalama başarısız olmuşlar
ortalamaları Linked an biraz daha iyi
Kendi payıma doğrusunu isterseniz ben de
bu ortalamayı düşürür müyüm yükseltir
miyim bilmiyorum ama bu okuldan mezun
olduktan 58 yıl sonra beni sizlerle
buluşturan her ne başarıp ya da
Başarılarını olduysa onların hepsini
öncesinde büyük Hayal kırıklıkları
yaşadığım acılar Hatta çekti
iyi bakın bunu söyleyecektim ama sen Şen
Olur dinleyecek aklıma geldi benim de
hayalet Tarsus'ta iken
sporcu olmak tutkulu bir taraftar uzun
Beşiktaş'ta forma giymek vardı hatta son
senemde parçası futbol takımında Kaptan
oldu ama yeter evli tartışmayalım
kapatalım
ayağımı Mersin Lisesi yaptığınız maçta
Kırım hem de bileğimi çıkartınca En
azından yetenek tartışmasında dan
kendimi Azade tutmuş oldu aynı şekilde
tarz bitirdikten sonra Ankara
Üniversitesi siyasal bilgiler
fakültesine girdim hayalim Diplomat
olmak
bu okulun ilk yılında akademik yaşamın
büyüsüne kendimi kaptırdım ve okulda
kalıp öğretim üyesi olmak bak ona
odaklan
yok Yalnız
1967-68 yıllarında öğrenci olaylarını
Zirve yaptı bir dönemde siyasal da
Mülkiye'de tarihsel adıyla öğrenci
Derneği Başkanı seçildim yazılar
çizgiler
eylemler eylemden eyleme hakkında
onlarca dava açıldı bir ara tutuklandı
Bu ikinci plana düşmüş olsa da Diplomat
olma hayalim yok olmuş Dışişleri
Bakanlığı'nın sınavına dahi görmedim
öğretim üyesi olmaya gelince okulda
sınava alındım sınavı da kazandım
Ama
hedefimdeki siyaset bilimi kürsünün
başındaki hocamız bir davrandı bilirkişi
olarak atanmıştı hakkında olumlu bir
rapor yazmıştı ama sanırım benimle
çalışmaktan korkmuştu o seni kimseyi
kimseyi almadım
de çaresizlikten
sevgili genç arkadaşlarım
belki hatırlamazlar ama
salonda
biraz yaşı daha büyük olanlar bilecek
ünlü gazeteci İlhan Selçuk'un sözüyle
hiçbir o tarih itibariyle hiçbir yerde
dikiş tutturamayanlar mesleği olan
gazeteciliğe başladı
bu arada
beni tanıtırken derken söylediler
Askerliğimi de sevgili Uğur Mumcu ile
birlikte sakıncalı piyade olarak yaptım
Milli Savunma Bakanlığı benim sevgili
vururum
bırakın
yedek subay olarak Aslı hemen
omuzuna Demir takmasını
Ben Ordu'da Onbaşı dayım olmasına Hakkı
olmadığını ortaya koymuştur
düşüncelerimizde değil böyle bir karar
vermiş
gazetecilikten sonra siyasetli
yaşamamız
milletvekili seçildim meclis başkan
vekili oldu meclis başkanvekili olunca
meclis başkanlığını da
bu iki kez toplam 52 saat
Cumhurbaşkanlığı'na vekalet
iyi bakın ben
o rütbesiz sakıncalı piyade
bu işte iki kez 52 saat
bu Türk Silahlı Kuvvetleri'nin
başkomutanlığı temsil Ee protokol
işlerinde s Cumhurbaşkanı karşılamaya
Sas meclis başkanı Nurlan vesaire ye
Genelkurmay başkanlarının önünde
yürüttüm
bu sakıncalı piyade elimi başarısızlık
olarak kabul etmiyor
O
cumhurbaşkanlığı'nın resmi de başarı
olarak kabul etme ama İtiraf edin
bu içimde kendime sakladığım şimdi sizle
paylaştım işte rövanş duygusunu da tek
bastıra bilmiştir
çok iyi
abone ol
ve siyasi yaşamın sırasında aktif
söylendiği gibi Avrupa Konseyi ve Agit
Avrupa Güvenlik ve İşbirliği Teşkilatı
larında da şey yap
görev yaptığı Türk grubu başkanı yaydım
oralarda Başkan Yardımcısı görevinde
oldum Evet kariyer diploması Diplomat
olmamıştım ama kariyerde
parlamenter diploma senin için de
yaşadım
var ya uykuya gelebildim
en iyi şey gelince
[Müzik]
sporculuk
haline
kendimi avutuyorum sevgili sipariş ana
kadar söyledim son 15 yıldır Beşiktaş
Jimnastik Kulübü'nün genel kurullarının
Divan başkanlığına büyük ölçüde
yapıyorum
Yıldırım Demirören de Fikret otyam da
Ahmet Nur Çebi de benim Divan başkanı
olduğu oturumlarda seçildi işte kendimi
avutuyorum
oh oh Yiğit Kardeşim bir şey buldum işte
bu tecrübelerin deneyimlerin Paylaşılmaz
bu anlayışta kıssadan hissediyorum ve
Yiğit gene Biz hayal kuruyoruz demişti
Hayal kurmaya devam et ama bu
hayallerinizi
bir belirlediğiniz Hedef hedefle
bütünleştirir İsmail kardeşimin dediği
gibi
ve o hayalleriniz hedeflerini sizi
kısıtlamasına Ama
onların uğruna o doğrultuda da
mücadeleden de hiçbir zaman baz geçmeyin
Evet 1 2 3 başarısız olur
bu gerekirse hedefinizin doğrusunu
gözden geçirin bakın İsmail kardeşim
sporcu olan adımı yılın en başarılı
sporcu ödülü aldı O benim yaşadıklarım
bir kenara şaka yer Diplomat olamadım
ama parlamenter diploması içinde yaşadım
vazgeçmediğini sürecek
bu başarıya odaklandığını
bu İsmail kardeşim sözüyle
başarıya dönük yolculuğunuzu kendisi bir
öyle olayların akışına bırakmadan ama
hedefleriniz hayalleriniz doğrultusunda
ve başarı vurduğuna devam ettiğiniz
sürece
mutlaka
kazanacaksınız
Bundan hiç kuşkunuz olmaz
çok değerli kardeşlerim bakın başarı hoş
bir başarısızlık hoş bir duygu değildir
bir moral Bozar Hatta utaç
verebilir Bu
var ama kendinizi rüt fen
bu başkanı
başarısızlığı İsra haline getirme
O ruh halinde sıyrılıp
Bu
başarısızlık larınızı fırsata
başarısızlıklarını zdan aldığınız
derslerle
yeni bir gelecek ilk konuşmacı mız Sayın
Meltem Eğer vurguladığı gibi
bir belirsiz boşluk bu olmaktansa
hedefiniz doğrultusunda
yapacağınız Biz kararlı bir gülüş
doğrultusuna çevirmeye
çalışacağım Eğer kendinizi başarısız ağ
teslim ederseniz bilin ki yaşamda
kendinize yapacağınız
en büyük
Zarar vermiş olursunuz Öncelikle
özgüveninizi getirmiş olursunuz ikinci
bir zarar da
çok iyi
ya Hani bir laf vardır
Sabreden derviş muradına
böyle bir bir girdaba kendinizi kaptırıp
Hiçbir şey yapmadan beklemede kalmayı
bir gün Piyango bana vuracak algısına
kapılmayın o yolculuğu o bekleyişin
hiçbir olumlu sonucu olamaz
başarısızlıkla en az başarı kadar doğal
bir süreçtir
var Ancak
Ama kalıcı değil geçici olur Eğer
kendinizi başarısızlığa teslim eder ama
başarıyı bekler durumda kalırsanız
başarıyı kalıcı hale dönüştürmüş
olursunuz
başarı gelip geçebilmektedir Öz
eleştirinizi yapabiliyor
eksiklerinizi saptıyor o
eksikliklerimizi gidermek için elinizden
geleni yapıyor ve kendinize Yeni
değerler kazandırıyor sanız
mutlaka başarılı olacaksınız bu sizin
çabanıza bağlı
bunun için ve kendinizi tam kapasiteli
izle
Evet
Ee hazır hale getirmeyi olacaktı
bunun benim deneyimlerinden elde ettiğim
iki yolu var bir
içinizdeki deli
chiriqui
kendinizi tanıtın içinizdeki be deyince
bakın Her insanın yaşı deneyimi Her ne
olursa olsun içinde gizli güçleri vardır
özel değerleri vardır bunların
keşfedilip bulup ortaya çıkarılması
sizin kapasitemizi arttıracaktır Ama
buna giden ilk yol
kendinizi tanımaktır
bu çift
bu şekilde Kendinizi sorgulamaktır
bu kendini tanımak içsel bir süreçtir
bu benlik
o özsaygı
Özgüven
gibi öz-yeterlik gibi kişisel değerleri
içerir
da aynı şekilde
alışkanlıklar
duyarlılıklar
inançlar
önyargılar gibi kişisel özel özellikleri
de kapsar
bunların ı bulunup ortaya çıkarılması
sizin
gerçekten en önemli bir yolculuğa hazır
olmanızı Ömür burada Bence en önemli
noktalardan neydi de değil biri de
kişinin kendisi tanıması anlamında
kişinin kendisini kendi kimliğiyle
kabullenmesidir bunun için önemsiyoruz
bu gerçekten kolay bir iş değildir bu
özellikle de Türkiye bakın bizim 11
[Müzik]
çok kötüyüm
var Osmanlı'dan miras kötü bir
kültürümüz demeyeceğim çünkü süzdüğümüz
var Osmanlı Türk'ü nasıl tanımlanır bu
etrakı bi idrak idraksız kavramsız
Osmanlı bitmiş Cumhuriyet kurulmuş ama
biz Bilerek ya da bilmeyerek hala bu şu
kültürsüzlük devam ediyoruz herhangi bir
zorlukla karşılaştığınızda ne diyoruz
ama biz adam olmayız
ve kendimizi kaba cahil kavgacı
disiplinsiz
da bu şekilde tanımıyoruz
en iyi yani çıkıp sadece güç konusunda
söz konusu ise
Bir Türk Dünyaya Bedeldir on düşmana
bedeldir gibi saçmalıyoruz ama bu
gerçekten biz
bu adam olmayız Türk'ün aklı Sonradan da
gelir gibi bir anlamda bütün Kimliğimizi
annemizden babamızdan olduğumuz kimliği
i ayaklarımızın altında istiyoruz Bir de
böyle gelmiş böyle gider Burası
Türkiye'deki var
ve bu içinde sıkıştırılmış bir
edilgenlik
o zamanın ve değişen dünyanın koşulları
karşısında çaresizliği teslimiyeti
bu durumları değiştirme azmini yokluğunu
gelecek tasarımının eksikliğini
sayılarda mi söylediği gibi geleceği
belirsiz bir boşlukta kalıcı olarak
bırakmanın ifadesidir yazmalıdır bir
kendimizi bundan Arındır mamız lazım
dünyanın bir dilinde de hiçbir
kültüründe
kendisini böylesine aşağılayan kendisini
böylesine yoksa ya
12. sınıf noktasına iten halkıyla
birlikte bir ezber biz bu ezberi birim
mutlaka ve de mutlaka aşa bilmeliyiz
zaten Atatürk'ün bakın kimilerinin üçü
bir yaklaşımdır
bunun kıvırdı
kimilerinin Efendim Türk'ün Türk'e
programda sı diye
Budak şu
küpü çalış güven sözü buna
amaçlamaktadır oradaki öğün sözü bir
böbürlenme değildir Tam aksine oradaki
öğün sözü
kendini Kendin olarak kabul et şimdi ile
Varol anlamına gelmektedir ben bu dersi
yine Tarsus'ta
1964 yılında son sınıfta şimdi ne var mı
bilmiyorum ama ekonomi dersinde
Amerikalı bir hocam da ve mısır Mert o
zaman aynı zamanda Okulu Müdürlüğü
dersteyiz sınıftayız bir arkadaşımızın
gömleğini şu cebi bütünüyle mürekkepli
kız o tarihlerde bu tükenmez kalemler
yeni çıkıyordu o
mı böyle bir en ufak bir olayda patlar
sıcakta patlardı işte yere düşer
patlardı elimiz yüzümüz üstümüz başımız
mektup olurdu arkadaşımız Yeminle
bir yerden
tükenmez kalem eline aldın ister
meyvelerde bu ne diye sorduğunda Turkish
Bath
Ne İster maillard bitiş öfkelendi
ceketini
i önünü açtı
içebilir gösterdi Koskocaman bir
bileklik size yani de size ne merakım
pembe dedi
ve Bu bana işte hep Türk öğün çalış
güven sözünün anlamını
Bu bir idrak dinlen Türk olarak kavrama
hem de
Eurovision'u kendimi ile varmak
kimliğimle barışma Biz yolunu vermiş
oldu
iyi bu üstünde gerçekten çok şükür Biz
kendimizi aşağı ağladığımız sürece
hiçbir yere başaramayız hiçbir yere
gidemeyiz
geleceği de tasarlamayı zsa DC boşlukta
işte bir belirsiz olayları Biz nereye
sürüklerse oraya gideceğimiz bir
yolculukta bırakırız yolculuğumuzu da
planlamalıyız
geleceğimizi de hayal etmeliyiz
hedeflerini ortaya koyabilir miyiz
sevgili Yiğit zeytinyağı olarak Bu
bağlamda gümbür gümbür geliyoruz buna
inanıyorum üniversitelerde ders veriyor
ama onu da söyleyeyim bakın işte
bu gece olmadı ama 20 yıldır
Bu üniversite lerde lisans ve yüksek
lisans ders veriyorum yani Hiçbir
akademik sıfatım yok Ama öğrencilerin
bana hocam dediği zaman da büyük bir
keyif alıyorum ama o hayalim olur
Yok olmuştu Ama görüntüyü geldi Bunu da
bir parantez olarak eklemiş olduk
Ama
gerçekten
Son olarak şunu vurayım
ve o gümbür gümbür gelişini sevgili
gelişini sevgili gençler daha düştü daha
kalıcı 7 söylediği gibi mm 40'lı yıllara
değil daha önce çekmek istiyorsanız
muhtaç olduğumuz Kudret
Atatürk'ün damarlarımızdaki kan diye
tanımladığı
içinizdeki bendedir odadaki
damarlarımızdaki kan vurgusu da 13 sal
aidiyet bir ırksal üstünlük iadesi
değildir
içinizdeki
bendir onun teşviğini istemek onun
keşfine sizi de yönlendirmektir bu
[Müzik]
bu toplantının bir anlamda temasıyla
uyumlu olarak şunu da söylemek isterim
o içinizdeki Ben duası gelir size
yabancı değil
Bugün sizinle birlikte sadece keşke sizi
bekliyor
Ama siz de ona yabancı kalmayın keşfedin
yolunuz açık ve başarıyla dolu olsun o
abone ol